when you're youngest the number one
strategy is to try to start something
around the thing you enjoy the most
because you have the most time to invest
at this point around that strategy
there's nothing there's nothing greater
in the world than loving what you do and
supporting the lifestyle that you want
and the best way to do that is to start
as early as possible because you have
years that you can put in to try to get
there it's much harder when you're 42
and have all these expenses it's still
the right move at 42 as a side hustle
until you can go off of your actual
business and do it but listen to me and
listen to me good build a media company
around your biggest passion or flip
stuff around your biggest passion flip
sports cards Pokemon cards sneakers
clothes or start the number one podcast
and Instagram and YouTube channel around
that subject Media or retail around the
thing that drives you the most